hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you how the hell
are ya
sorry I'm a little bit late today and
sorry I am speaking in a hushed voice
but I'm doing that because I got it the
little baby boy came this week I become
a dad again my wife gave birth to a
beautiful baby boy and we couldn't be
more excited yeah so I'm not getting a
lot of sleep but it's totally worth it
and it's a basic when you watch your
wife go through a pregnancy she sit
there going like I never want to do this
this is it I'm done I am done you hear
me stay away from me I'm done and you're
just sitting there going like I'm sorry
I'm sorry I did this to you I'm sorry
right and then the second you have the
kid about two hours later it's like you
won't have another one this is kind of
friggin Oh I mean how often do you get
to see a miracle you know you could make
a miracle and have fun while you're
doing it hey you know what I'm saying
fellas yeah so that's it I have a son
and a daughter I got one of each and I
feel like the luckiest guy on the planet
right now and you know amidst all of
this crazy stuff that is going on that I
do believe something positive is going
to come out of all of this I've seen a
lot of photos of police officers talking
to protesters and and all of that type
of stuff while the [ __ ] weirdest dude
I've seen in recent memory I don't know
what the hell he's doing
yeah I'm trying to stay away from that
[ __ ] I really hate doing the politics
things but you know I I'm not living a
life here where I'm just quarantined so
I got to go can I go with the
low-hanging fruit all right not talking
politics or anything like that here
people but that is one weird
son of a [ __ ] oh yeah I'm gonna I've
got a walk across the street teargas
everybody and then I'm gonna stand with
a scowl on my face holding up a Bible in
front of a [ __ ] church oh my god
there was so many funny memes about that
I mean that you basically could have
done it to anybody I mean if I stood
there holding a Bible then you could say
all this [ __ ] that I said with but did
you see that one where they had him
saying I just walked out - grab him by
the [ __ ] like they had that written
there where they would say you know when
the masses were anyway
oh jeez drew brees got himself in hot
water oh my god
Jesus Christ you know back in the day
when you just had thoughts you just said
them to the people in your house why do
people feel the [ __ ] as I do a podcast
by myself telling you everything that
I'm thinking why do people feel the need
especially when you're making that kind
of money a [ __ ] year why in god's
name would you go and do that you've got
to ask yourself why would you do that
well it's simple it's a it's you know
it's easy that's not what it is I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is but I do know
this I found the reaction to that so
[ __ ] hilarious like if you look at
what drew like okay go back to
Kaepernick right and Kaepernick takes
Anil Anil takes a knee during the
national anthem and says this is about
people of color I'm protesting about the
way they're treated in this country the
second-class citizens and blah blah blah
right and then everybody on the other
side was like a man don't disrespect a
flag you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] others
you know my uncles are not [ __ ] you
know Navy SEALs fighting for your
freedom and all this [ __ ] so everyone
when that was going down on the Left was
just like well hey man like first of all
that's not the issue the issue is this
it's not that
and isn't he it doesn't have free speech
to like do what he wants
part of his freedom if he can do it say
last right and all the people on the
right who are engaging we're all like
you [ __ ] Lib [ __ ] [ __ ] snowflake
limousine liberal all that [ __ ]
right
fast forward drew brees writes his whole
[ __ ] right his take on you know the
protesting and the riots and all of that
type of [ __ ] and then it was literally
the exact opposite all the people on the
left like you're [ __ ] [ __ ] canceled
his mother [ __ ] and then everybody on
the rights like well hey man like he's
just expressing his opinion man like
what's everybody getting so upset for me
like they literally like change roles
like I remember a long time ago I saw
this play true West all right I don't
know what it was like the late 90s I saw
this this play true West and it had
Philip Seymour Hoffman and and
what's-his-face john c reilly
and every other performance they would
they would switch roles and i'll it
that's the first thing that just
reminded me of like how everybody on the
right was like you know you you don't
have a right to this [ __ ] opinion
you're a [ __ ] pieces you know hey I
have the [ __ ] right to react to what
he's doing and in in take whatever he's
trying to say and make what I you know
Frey everybody's like a catcher trying
to frame every ball like it's a strike
to fit their [ __ ] argument and now
the left is doing the exact same thing
to [ __ ] drew brees alright I didn't
agree with what the guy said but you got
you're gonna cancel the guy you know
he's doing basically what everybody does
I listen my G's adjust my opinion sir I
really believe there there are two
universes that everybody lives in the
actual universe and the one between your
ears
alright and the one between your ears is
so [ __ ] vivid
because you have all the pain all the
triumphs all the love all the hate all
of the [ __ ] that's happened to you
between your [ __ ] ears so there's no
way anybody can tell you that that
that's not [ __ ] reality so when
people open the [ __ ] hole in their
head and they start spewing out words
this they're basically saying you know
where where they are in the [ __ ]
universe that's all it is you don't have
to agree with it but I don't think
attacking drew brees because you didn't
like what he said is any more healthier
than attacking Kaepernick for what he
said especially if you're trying to go
in some sort of positive direction to
try to bring people together you know I
just you know it's like all right I
don't agree with that but I'm not gonna
argue with your your right to say it
but in no way would I ever take what the
[ __ ] he said and try to spin it to my
own [ __ ] political things you know
now this is just I'm talking as a white
person here now somebody of color
obviously is going to have an immediate
visceral reaction to what the [ __ ] that
guy said which I understand that but
like all the white people jumping in and
that type of [ __ ] and just the [ __ ]
lying that is done on social media
because it was this it was sort of a
funny mean but it was it showed a
picture of everybody that was supporting
what Drew Brees was saying it was a
bunch of white people and they all had
some like these dark sunglasses on and
I'm thinking like there's no [ __ ] way
everybody they agreed with them had the
dark sunglasses on what they did was
they got a bunch of them then they got a
bunch that looked alike and then posted
it so they could further solidify their
[ __ ] point which in a way is a lie
the whole thing is [ __ ] bizarre I
don't know what is going on but uh I I
don't get that you're gonna cancel you
said something I don't like I'm gonna
cancel you you know you're kneeling
during the national anthem I'm gonna
call the owner of the team and say I'm
not buying any more jerseys until that
guy stands up shut the [ __ ] up a bunch
of [ __ ] lunatics lunatics you're an
adult somebody said something you don't
agree with
fine okay that's it you don't have to
politicize [ __ ] I don't know I don't
know what I mean I think you know drew
brees it's like all right if you don't
like what the guy said I mean this
initial the initial angry reaction I get
that but then you know maybe that will
lead him towards some sort of I don't
know coming towards the middle let's get
in the middle everybody huh we're all
rocking the boat here let's get in the
[ __ ] middle all right how about
something positive here I got a bunch of
people I need to thank here first of all
my lovely wife for going through
everything that she went for and just
gave me the most beautiful baby boy I
could have ever asked for and one of the
great moments in my life was seeing my
daughter meet my son for the first time
and I was like all nervous because like
you know she's been the star of the show
and I'm like wow is this gonna be like a
a co-star you know situation and she's
gonna be like wait um I thought I had
all the lines why is this person taking
half my lines and it was it was the
exact opposite when she saw him she's
like went like she took like a breath
and put her little hand up to her mouth
man it was so cool and she's absolutely
fascinated by him and all of that which
was why I feel like I'm lucky that I had
a daughter first because the way little
girls it's amazing their reaction to
babies you see like that motherly
instinct and like little boys generally
speaking could give a [ __ ] they just
look they're like yeah cool and then
like go and [ __ ] break something hold
it so anyway I was supposed to do a
bunch of press over the next couple days
obviously I can't because I'm gonna be
changing diapers and trying to sleep and
doing all that type of stuff so there's
a few people I just wanted to thank I
want to thank everybody over at
Universal Judd Apatow Pete Davidson
everybody else for you know being
understanding that I couldn't do the
press thank you guys all so much and I
was supposed to do
Richard herrings Leicester Square
theater podcast and we're definitely
try to reschedule that I'm trying to
reschedule as much of the stuff that I
can as we sort of just get ourselves you
know solidified here but thank you for
all them they were so Universal
everybody was so cool
John everybody was so cool like no no we
get it we get it don't worry don't worry
but you know part of being in these
things part of having the privilege of
being in a movie is you got to help sell
the hell out of it and let people know
that it's happening so if you guys could
do me a little solid the way Universal
Jud and everybody else did me a solid
over the next couple days a few guys on
June 12th the king of Staten Island will
be streaming if you guys it's a [ __ ]
hilarious movie I think my own biased
opinion if you guys and and Peter so
amazing and it's such a incredible story
i if you can watch it I would really I
would really appreciate it so there you
go
all right there huh is this positive
stuff people can say things and people
can get angry about him but then you
know you don't have to [ __ ] how do
you cancel a quarterback you know it's
not like he was on the [ __ ] was that the
Dragons out in the field say what the
[ __ ] was the show I can't [ __ ]
remember Laura they're not Lord of the
Rings come on everybody was watching it
had the little evil king I wanted to
watch it my wife wasn't into it it was
just too many episodes to just you know
you get when does that many [ __ ] Epis
king of Game of Thrones
king of Thrones Game of Thrones when
there's that many [ __ ] episodes and
you're married and you're sleeping in
the same bed like there has to be you
got to come to the middle it's like we
have to pick we got to pick a show oh by
the way I saw a [ __ ] amazing [ __ ]
goddamn show Jesus I gotta clean up my
mouth here and I got two kids and I
could Bruin here I want to make sure I
get everybody's yeah Amanda Peet is in
this I forget what the name of the
[ __ ] show is she plays this woman
Oh does she built with Christian Slater
they play this married couple that's
based on a true story dirty secrets is
what it's called dirty secrets
oh geez the Betty Broderick story and I
gotta tell you something Amanda Peet's
performance in this thing is so friggin
incredible and then I actually looked up
the real woman that she's playing
because I was like going like was this
woman this unhinged and then I just I
just saw pictures of her I was just like
wow she is nailing this thing and
Christian Slater is absolutely crushing
at playing the her ex-husband and it is
[ __ ] wild I think it's on the USA
Network we started watching I mean I
sort of paratroops into this thing where
they I don't know how many episodes in
they were but I'm gonna go back and
watch this stuff but Jesus Christ what a
performance and what a creepy story -
and it's kind of funny it was like
basically the overall story me could
read the overall story if you don't a
spoiler alert just fast-forward to have
a couple minutes here but it was
basically you know man and woman get
married they had an old-school
relationship where she stayed at home as
a stay-at-home mom he continued to work
built his career at one point he went
after finishing medical school he
decided to get a law degree he's gonna
be a lawyer and then he was gonna do
I guess malpractice law or something
like something that had to do with
medicine or something that legal
legalities of Medicine right so when he
went back to law school she became the
primary breadwinner and then he became a
lawyer and did all that you know and
became you know what the hell he wanted
to be and then their marriage went south
and he was having an affair with some
chick he was working with that was like
way younger than her and yada yada yada
and so she snapped
and now she's in jail we'll put it that
way try not to ruin this for you and
what was funny was it was like this
story this case was groundbreaking
because it opened up the whole topic of
you know women sacrificing their own
careers for their guys and then kind of
being left with nothing and I have to
hand it to women only women in a double
murder case could still somehow make it
about themselves you know because it is
a legit argument if you're sitting there
and you you're taking a back seat well
your partner is getting all these
credits and everything and then gets
this ridiculous earning power as you
supported them financially and then they
walk yeah that's definitely [ __ ] up
but it's kind of a weird time to bring
it up after the woman who was in that
situation killed two people I mean
that's when you're kind of like I don't
think that's the biggest issue here
right now I think maybe mental health
might be the issue I don't know that
just it's just the whole I was gonna say
sorry I got the dad brain here I just
struck me as [ __ ] hilarious that
during that time you know what I mean
like if a guy killed a woman and then
during that time that you know it aren't
that case okay a guy kills a woman and
it brings up this criticism that men
have for women just imagine a world
where you could pull that off you know I
mean ladies you just got out you got to
understand you know when your husband's
about ready to snap and just have you
got he got it you have to at some point
let him sit on a couch and put his feet
up a man sitting down is not a trigger
for you now to think of something that
you could tell him to go do right can
you imagine bringing up that kind of
[ __ ]
once you know oh you know what that
reminds me of that guy killing his
ex-wife you know that reminds me of my
wife has this thing that she does just
just hear me out this is all gonna come
full circle anyway I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about on this podcast
people I guess you know I got maybe two
hours three hours sleep last night my
swaddle game is flatlined I mean I came
in I'm not gonna lie to you I came in a
little cocky you know I mean I was
watching the you know the rookie that
they put in starting and I was sitting
there you know looking like the grizzled
vet on the sidelines like I got this
he's gonna [ __ ] up and then I'm gonna
guy but I've been through this [ __ ]
before two minutes left in the game I
got this [ __ ] I've done it before
completely forgot how to do it just
failing miserably changing a poopy
diaper while looking at a VIP watching a
video how to swaddle my boy is strong
man you know it's all about getting that
first arm down and then you bring it
across and then he's kind of like locked
in and he just he just like powers his
way back up through it granted my
swaddle games a little off but and he
was definitely voicing his displeasure
he was definitely arguing the call when
I was doing that so anyway I'm just
psyched that we're home that's that's
always the big thing you know when you
have the kid my big thing is you just
want happy healthy all of that stuff and
then the next thing is like I just want
to get everybody home I never feel
relaxed until we're home so now we're
finally home and
can sorta I guess he can't relax because
I still you know freak out about [ __ ]
but like at least I'm in a comfort zone
of my house I'll tell you it was
hilarious like the night before my wife
went into labor I was like I was looking
at dirt bikes online and I want to tell
you why I was doing that not because I'm
an idiot I mean that that's sort of a
given but I was just sort of on this one
I was like really in denial
of the the level of work that I knew
because the first time I I didn't I had
no idea right what was ahead of me and
this time I did so I was so excited when
my wife was pregnant through about mid
second trimester trimester sorry
Tremezzo
that's semester and trimester for you
keeping score at home so I think I was
just like in denial I was psyched that I
was having another kid but I was also
like dreading the lack of sleep and then
thinking like oh god again and I already
have a kid I have to be watching like
how the hell is this whole thing gonna
work so you know I was just you know
watching helicopter videos and dirt bike
videos and somebody sent me this a buddy
of mine he just bought this thing I
never even heard of these bikes I don't
know what the new te 250 I takes the low
maintenance simplicity of a two-stroke
it makes it even simpler with the aid of
electronic fuel injection see I love
that right off the bat I'm an old guy I
want to kick-start this [ __ ] thing is
some [ __ ] black bears sizing me up in
the middle of nowhere I want to just
start it up and get the [ __ ] out of
there this means that fueling is self
adjusted removing the need for jetting
changes while two-strokes
two-stroke oil is pumped independently
at regulated ratios eliminating the need
to premix fuel whether you are riding at
different altitudes in varying terrain
or changing temperature fuel injection
ensures a perfectly controlled power
delivery every time so it burns cleaner
it lasts longer it's easy to start and I
believe a two-stroke versus a
four-stroke is the amount of time like
two strokes is it fires it goes the
piston goes down comes back up it fires
every time it goes to the top of the
cylinder where a four-stroke is like
bang two three four bang two as it's
going up and down and I restored the
four strokes were cleaner but they
weren't as quick which I was totally
into I'm not a speed guy right I like
Dan's pickup trucks not the [ __ ]
souped-up ones either I'd like to just
the [ __ ] you know I mean I like to
have some horses under the hood day I'm
not gonna lie but I yeah I just like
[ __ ] I'm just more fascinated by them
you see you know back when I used to fly
helicopters I think I'll get back to it
someday yeah I was never into doing like
crazy [ __ ] you know like I had a buddy
my just texted me right he just told me
the stories he [ __ ] he was flies out
and like [ __ ] I don't know somewhere
in mid with the Midwest he told me there
was a suspension bridge and he flew
underneath it I go get the [ __ ] out here
I go I didn't know you could do that I
go is that legal and he was just like
you know I don't know lol he goes but I
was flying with my dad so I had to do it
right so it was hilarious cuz then my
next text to him was like oh by the way
you know my wife gave birth to a baby
boy a couple days ago because Jesus
Christ I would have led with that
and I was like well you know I didn't
want to take the steam out of you're
taking your dad under a suspension
bridge so um I don't know dad Brian I
want the [ __ ] point of that story was
uh was there a point that probably
wasn't a point there's no point to this
[ __ ] thing so anyway yeah I was just
looking at a bunch of stuff like that
and like I always wanted to learn how to
ride a motorcycle and those who have
listened this podcast for a long time I
know some like six seven years ago I
took the motorcycle safety course I
learned how to ride one and then I rode
one around la for like two months and I
haven't ridden sense just because
somebody almost took my head off the way
people are texting while driving out
here and I was just you know it was
funny what I didn't even think about
dying I thought about like [ __ ] up my
leg or losing a leg and not being able
to play drums and I was just like I
can't do that you know so now I'm like
well if I get a dirt bike I can still
like that's one of those man things you
just want to know how to do it you want
to know how to [ __ ] ride a motorcycle
right so I'm thinking I could you know
go out in the dirt
trails or whatever and but then you get
out there and then you got to worry
about like you know you see these
[ __ ] videos of like [ __ ] mountain
lions and [ __ ] chasing people on
mountain bikes and stuff I don't know I
always like get freaked out about
there's always something you got to
worry about this is why I stopped riding
a motorcycle because I was riding scared
so I was going to get hit sooner rather
than later so I decided against that but
I have to [ __ ] tell you though man
like I absolutely love them you know I
[ __ ] love them and I go on YouTube
and I watch those videos of these
[ __ ] young kids just doing crazy [ __ ]
and which i think is stupid because
you've taken other people's lives in
your hands at that point but like I kind
of gravitate towards the the old man
bikes the big bikes you know which I was
wondering for guys who ride who listen
to this podcast if you get a bigger bike
like that I have to think it's safer in
that people can kind of see I mean some
of those bikes when you get like the
windscreen on the front you're you you
are as big as a smart car right
I know virzi always said it best to me
he goes dude the fact that you're
writing something down the street that
you could just fall off of you know you
can't fall off a car unless you're
riding you're basically riding on the
outside of a two-wheeled car and that
you can go that fast is just insane and
then I also find it amazing the amount
of people that are terrified of a
motorcycle but in two seconds they would
get on a [ __ ] scooter without even
thinking about it and it's just like so
are you just scared of the speed or are
you just scared of having to know how to
like shift and downshift and turn and
all I mean like I like it's just such a
weird thing it's like it's kind of like
sharks and killer whales like that face
a shark in the water no one's going in
the water but if there's like a killer
whale they're like Oh SeaWorld and I've
been watching these videos and like
killer whales eat sharks and legit
shocks a killer whale can [ __ ] eat a
great white shark for some reason they
don't [ __ ]
humans is much but you know the way
we're fishing out the ocean you got to
think at some point we're gonna be on
the menu and not to mention every once
in a while they do kill their instructor
down there at the SeaWorld right
is there a word for that you know like
if you kill your mom it's matricide
patricide is there a word for killing
your boss let's see a mattress side what
a thing to look up
patricide what is killing your boss
called boss Assad list of types of
killings oh Jesus
all right oh it's all side suicide we
all know that one auto side suicide by
automobile meta side oh these are all
the sewers cat killing self this suicide
auto side meta side murder-suicide self
immolation suicide is a form of protest
often by fire [ __ ] suicide by cop acting
in a threatened manner as to provoke a
lethal response from law enforcement
alright there's a major joke I could
make there but I'm trying not to divide
people here okay alright killing of
other people all of these types are
considered homicide you know what's so
[ __ ] up I never noticed that side was
at the end of everything killing of
family all right you guys want to get
dark here what a vocal side I swear to
govern coal side is the killing of an of
an uncle familicide is multiple victim
homicide with a killer spouse and
children are slow I don't want to get
into this I'll just read them filicide
fraternity recite Jarrow - so sad let's
get out of the killing of the family
here killing of others casualty death in
wartime collateral damage death during
wartime due to him
precise or incorrect Tiger targeting or
friendly fire all right this is all
depressing oh here here's what I was
getting killing of superiors deicide
killing a God or divine being
Epis cup aside killing a bishop Oh piss
a Pisgah piss Cup apply sides if I can
see this [ __ ]
killing of a king killing of a tyrant
Tyrannis side so isn't that maybe that'd
be like if you thought your boss was
that bad I don't give somebody a defense
for doing that that was a weird place to
go to I don't know why I don't why am I
thinking this I just brought a life into
the world and now I'm talking about all
the different kinds of [ __ ] death and
with that I think it's a good time to do
a little advertising here oh but it'd be
undies
me undies killing your [ __ ] boss -
dude I can't do that I start over again
edit that out me undies okay
it's me undies everybody me undies me
undies there's nothing funny about death
- do do do me undies me undies until you
smell your [ __ ] breath between your
legs wear and tighty whities
everything's going off here put on some
me undies to give you junk some fresh
breath sorry alright me undies do you
guys know about a thing called June
gloom it's as sad it it it is is this
said simply because it rhymes three
hours sleep people and I'm dumb just
hang with me here
that's ridiculous what could possibly be
gloomy about Junie discovering those
undies in your mailbox while June's non
gloom sunshine is bronzing your
shoulders I would love to know what that
feels like at this point the situation
is hypothetical but we're gonna tell you
how to make it real biondi's has this
brilliant thing called the undies
membership where every month the softest
undies ever ever appear at your door the
convenience factor is clutch you never
have to leave the house oh and you
always get site-wide savings early
access and free
it's pure joy because when undies greet
you in your mailbox June gloom is doomed
me Indies are made from micro modality
and irresistible soft sustainable fabric
that encases your nether regions in a
cloud like comfort and cloud like
comfort it's magical
made from trees another reason to give
them a hug me undies well it's made from
try that's weird why would you give it a
hug like you guys a hippies here me
undies are offered in a range of sizes
from extra small to four XL me undies
has a great offer from my listeners for
any first-time purchasers you get 15%
off in free shipping you got to give
this super softness a try especially
because they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed to get your 15
percent off your first order free
shipping and hunterson satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com slash
bird that's my undies dot-com / /
alright o simply save something we all
want to be right now what's the number
one sign of a bad home security system a
home security system that's so
complicated you never use it Jesus
Christ I've been there this is exactly
the type of security system simply safe
has spent a decade fighting against they
believe that simple is safer and it's
exactly why simply safe is the home
security for right now when feeling safe
at home has never been more important
is that left over from kovat or is that
commenting on the other stuff that's
weird
simply safe has was designed to be easy
to use while protecting your whole home
24/7 order online with the click of the
button open the box place the sensor
plug it in and your home is protected
around the clock no technician or
salesperson has to come and disrupt your
house you don't need to pay any
outrageous monthly fees or sign a
two-year contract simply safe was named
Best Overall home security of 2020 by US
News & World Report and there 24/7
professional monitoring and emergency
dispatch starts at 50 cents a day head
to simply safecom slash berman get free
shipping and a 60 day money back
guarantee that simply safe calm / / SI
MPL i
komm slash burp bu are hard to make sure
they know that our show sent you oh look
who's here everybody stamps.com from
back in the day
the first advertisers ever stamps.com
for all our sakes we need to avoid
crowds any way we can right now but what
if you need to go to the post office
that's why that is why you need stamps
calm
anything you can do at the post office
you can do it stamps calm print postage
on demand and skip those lines and
crowds at the post office plus you can
actually save some money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office and if that wasn't enough stamps
calm also offers UPS services with
discounts up to 62 percent 62 percent
and no UPS residential surcharges you've
heard me talk about stamps calm they've
been sponsoring this show for over seven
years now and if you haven't tried it
what are you waiting for plus damn stock
stamps calm is completely online which
saves you time no more inconvenient
trips to the post office stamps Tom
brings all the service of the US Postal
Service right to your computer and the
safety and comfort of your own home
office or anywhere else you are
hunkering down right now
whether you are a small business sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or you're just working from
home and need to mail stuff stamps comp
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print US postage 24/7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send once your
mail is ready just leave it for your
mail carrier schedule is free schedule a
free package pick up or drop it in the
mailbox no human contact required it's
that simple right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Furby you are are at stamp
calm stamps calm enter BRR stay safe my
friends alright so there you go that is
the podcast everybody thank you all for
listening please June 12th watch the
king of Staten Island and season four of
f is for family
thank you to everybody listening out
there what else what else what else we
get a little bit of bonus music here and
then a not bonus we have a little bit of
music little music interlude here and
then a bonus half-hour episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast from a previous
Thursday a year ago ten years ago I
don't know how that all works all right
that's it I apologize if this was all
jumbled up everybody you know try to
come together let's try to work on this
try to become a better person so stuff
like this doesn't happen and oh yeah
remember kovat man they just kind of got
knocked right off the charts didn't they
huh knocked right off the charts like a
boyband that it there that's on their
third album Co vid just got sent [ __ ]
packing you know I'm surprised they
weren't all you know you can't Prout
we'd love to hear what you guys have to
say but unfortunately these types of
gatherings are not allowed not because
we're violating the Constitution we're
just trying to keep everybody safe so if
you guys would just protest six feet
apart from one another no groups larger
than five or six we would greatly
appreciate that tremendously appreciate
that all right that's it sorry that was
my last attempt at trying to be funny
I'm too [ __ ] tired I swear to god I'm
gonna get some sleep this weekend and
I'm gonna come back [ __ ] swinging on
what is it Monday Monday Monday all
right that's it
god bless you go [ __ ] yourselves and
I'll see have a great weekend it's bill
burr and it's the Monday morning podcast
for Monday June 4th 2012 2012 how are
you how's it going I know I know it's a
little late it's a little late but you
know can't you just go twiddle your
thumbs and do something else for a
minute you know instead of going on my
Twitter and breaking my balls I know
what you're thinking bill you don't
really don't have a [ __ ] day job so
there's really no excuse
if you have in this podcast late once
again well listen if you've noticed like
Axl Rose I am also a balding redheaded
performer and and we are notorious for
starting shows late for sitting in our
trailers you know making sure our kilts
fit correctly that's when you knew that
band was just [ __ ] really was just
going over the top and there was nobody
saying no in their camp when he came out
you know when he wore the kilt hey what
are you doing all right you're not
Scottish I'm sure you have some sort of
Scottish heritage you ginger vested in
your blood but you know you're from
[ __ ] Rhode Island or whatever
Indianapolis that was he from Illinois
what you're in America it's not a kilt
that's the st. Patrick's Day st.
Patrick's Day I'll look the other way
other than that you wearing a [ __ ]
dress you know and who stole it years
later Kurt Cobain came out wearing his
summer dress cuz he was sad and he
thought maybe if he felt a little pretty
that you know Jesus Phil you really
gonna say well [ __ ] it I'll say it maybe
he wouldn't stick a [ __ ] gun in his
mouth you know where the [ __ ] do you get
off making fun of it out [ __ ] you
believe it or not I'm actually in a
great mood the wrist is the reason why I
was late today this is Mike's this is my
the dog-ate-my-homework excuse was I
finally went out riding a motorcycle
today that's what I did I had a manly
morning what did you do huh
you sit down and eat some [ __ ] Lucky
Charms hi you pansy you sitting there
smelling like gas I don't think you are
um is there anything worse than when
somebody just picks up a new hobby and
then they go out and they just buy all
the gear and then they start walking
around like they're [ __ ] Clint
Eastwood well lucky for you guys I'm not
one of those guys and the only reason
why I'm not is because I'm an old
bastard now and one of the great things
about being an old bastard about being
an old bastard one of the great things
aside from having an enlarged prostate
is
is you know you limits you've gotten
[ __ ] up somebody kicked you in the
head by now you fell down a flight of
stairs
you [ __ ] up some relationships you
know people you know have gotten [ __ ]
at you you realize you realize that
there's not some dude in the air that
gives a [ __ ] about you you know that you
have some sort of guardian angel just
looking out for you
know if you're a [ __ ] idiot
eventually you're gonna get [ __ ] up
why is that true though there's a couple
of golden child's out there don't
doesn't everybody just know that guy
that you've just been predicting you
know what guys gonna get his [ __ ] ass
kicked I'm telling it's gonna happen
remember remember this conversation
remember I've said it okay [ __ ] guy
he doesn't show any respect he's always
running his [ __ ] Yap I tell you I
would have done it if I didn't have so
much to loose you know I would have
kicked his [ __ ] ass if XY and Z and
this scenario my wife wasn't yelling at
me you know and he just keep predicting
that this guy is gonna get his ass
kicked and you know there's always that
guy where it just never happens and once
they hit 40 and if you've never got your
ass kicked by 40 it's it's pretty much
not gonna happen unless there's some
sort of home invasion you know I would
think or unless for some reason you take
up drugs late in your life right you end
up eating somebody's [ __ ] face and
growling at the cops it's just you know
isn't it unbelievable that I I refuse to
watch that video and if you I if you
watch that video like before if you
haven't watched it yet you know just
there's a those videos that's like
getting just deliberately putting a
virus on your computer you don't want
that [ __ ] in your own personal hard
drive you don't want that you don't want
that rolling around in your head
you don't want to see that [ __ ] you have
a [ __ ] meet like you know veterans
who've really seen some [ __ ] be it
military or cops or whatever prison
guards they got that look on their face
they just seen too much [ __ ] Christmas
music starts fading away
in the background you just see why would
you deliberately do that to yourself
alright it already sound hurt horrific
enough it's already making my stomach
turn I mean that's just what kind of
world do we live in weather could
something like that app that's the new
drug I mean on one hand you got a hang
it hand it to the youngsters you know
every time you know you think your
generation is taking it to the limit the
next generation somehow figures out a
way to top you it's one of the great
things about human beings that's why
cars keep getting better right people
figure out how to make a sandwich a
little more tastier but just you just
keep improving and but that also goes
with evil [ __ ] and I always thought you
know the crack 80s when I saw crack
babies I was like that's it I don't know
how you top that you know some little
shiver and [ __ ] guinea pig of a kid
never had a goddamn chance comes out
addicted to crack how do you beat that
you know and then Along Came meth heads
right sounds like the beginning of some
spin-off sitcom
right like meth heads was the flow from
Alice to crack babies if you were making
a sitcom about drug use you know ma'am
kiss my grits that was [ __ ] meth
heads just go with me on this don't be
it what else you gonna do hunt go to
work sit in your cubicle and actually
get something done and earn a [ __ ]
living that's right wrinkle your [ __ ]
nose at me in my podcast what are you
doing huh you eatin those yellow Oreo
cookies you got down from the vending
machine not those tasty they are aren't
they now your blood Sugar's starting to
crash look at you big stupid head on
your hand acting like you're trying to
figure something out on your computer
you're not you know maybe you're in an
airport and you just finished off some
[ __ ] horrible food all right now
you're gonna go waddle your ass onto a
goddamn airplane what does it have to do
with anything
so anyways then yet meth heads who I
thought were basically real-life zombies
as far as far as you could take it and
then along comes this guy Along Came
Polly
right just like the movie except philip
Seymour Hoffman's eaten somebody's face
how great is that [ __ ] basketball
scene by the way ray dad's old old
schools the best eatin somebody's
goddamn face I refuse to believe that
that's the drugs fault I think you got
to be like already a maniac and then you
do some new psycho drug but who knows
maybe that's the new thing maybe that's
what the kids are doing and then the guy
[ __ ] survives and now you were in the
hospital I mean I would just be like
dude kill me I was laying in a hospital
bed and then they're acting like they're
gonna somehow [ __ ] do a face
transplant on me like from what I would
immediately just I would be just start
feeling around my hospital table for a
pen and I would just be like shoot me
actually you know what I wouldn't I
wouldn't because then they would be like
what we have to prevent him from doing
what he wants to do to himself right now
and so I actually I wouldn't say that I
would just write oh great on a post-it
and then stick it to my non-existent
forehead and I just keep pointing to it
every time they talk to me and then the
second I felt like I was alone how would
I do it
gotta be great just roll right out the
[ __ ] Hospital window with your ass
hanging out of the back of that robe I'm
sorry I felt bad for that guy and
everything I'm not making fun of that
guy but like I don't have the internal
strength like you ever see that [ __ ]
like when my Christopher Reeve gets
thrown off a horse hits the ground like
a [ __ ] lawn dart snaps his neck and
in the next Oscars he's whaling himself
out with this like tongue smiling at the
crowd like I feel fortunate to be alive
I feel lucky there's no [ __ ] way if
I'm ever presented with that challenge
then I'm going to handle that even
remotely
in a dignified way there's no [ __ ]
way I'm better I'm not as strong as
those people I'll just be I will just be
you know like I said sounds great was
gonna be right on my [ __ ] forehead
and I'm gonna steer my chair right down
a flight [ __ ] stairs and that's it
it's over I'm willing to roll the dice
you know about what happens after you
after here personally you know these
[ __ ] people who go through [ __ ] like
that and then are able to continue on
with their lives and like you see these
[ __ ] people they're like you know
writing a [ __ ] novel with their left
foot you know I'm sitting like girls
like take out the recycling like I mean
I just you know if there is a higher
power I think he knows who to [ __ ]
challenge he's taking a look at me again
Oh Gigi but let that one go
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] can't even make the
goddamn bed I'm gonna send him flying
off a [ __ ] horse he is serious so
anyways let's get on with my day here I
had a phenomenal day I went blank ridin
this morning for the first time ever
never rode a motorcycle and I got a
minute did alright I was driving around
for like an hour and then next thing you
know they talked me into going out on
the track where they had jumps and [ __ ]
and but it wasn't like you know they
were [ __ ] steep for me but they had
like the plateau so he could ride right
over him like a little [ __ ] which is
exactly what I did and it's why I didn't
get hurt a couple times so you know I
got into like second gear and I kind of
was like whoa when there was like a
[ __ ] fence with the telephone pole
and I was like yeah you know I don't
wanna be doing that I don't wanna be
[ __ ] laying there you know with my
rib cage slammed into all my vitals I
don't feel like doing that so I you know
I kept it slow then I got on the track
and was hilarious I thought I was flying
when I was on the track but someone was
taking video of it which I will give you
I will put up on the podcast page
hopefully if it's sent to me by the time
I post this I'll definitely at least
have some photos but I thought I was
flying right
that was flying then I watched the video
I look like looked like I was riding
like a [ __ ] moped but anyways I drove
around for like two hours got it down
pretty goddamn good and I only ate [ __ ]
once I was on the track and I don't know
even know what happened was like I was
up and then I wasn't I was like I got
it's going good man I'm gonna kick up
some dirt that was it
landed on my shoulder jacked up my thumb
a little bit and you know what I did the
old man and me said you know what Bill
you know what I think I think that's
good for a day I think that's good
I rode right off the track I went around
it one more time you know just so I'm
not like afraid of it and then I just
went over and I pulled up to the truck
and I got some water the instructor dude
came up say you want to ride around
again I think now you know what I think
I'm good one faceplant is good I got a
podcast I have to do I got the gist of
this [ __ ] I'll definitely be coming back
it's a great time man was such a good
time I took my truck out there I met the
buddy of mine he had the buddy who's got
a couple of bikes just just an adventure
today you know we got off at the exit
there was these two dogs that look
healthy they just running down the
[ __ ] highway tongues hanging out like
you know big spoon tongues and we were
pulled over picked him up gave him some
water
parked in the shade let him hang out
they're [ __ ] awesome dogs they were
filthy but they were well fed and they
had collars so we was hilarious like
right next to the track was this guy had
like a [ __ ] just was living in like a
double-wide like motocross you there for
two seconds did you just feel it it is
it is a white-trash sport that's why I
loved it you know my [ __ ] inner
redneck you know I mean you can just
feel it you don't gas gears meth the
whole [ __ ] thing was right there you
know mullets you know everybody there
sucked at math but they could convert a
lawnmower into like a [ __ ] Ferrari if
they had to you know
at least a Mustang that whole vibe so
right next to the track was this guy had
like a double-wide he had like [ __ ]
20 dogs so the dude who picked up the
dogs let's go let's just drop them cuz
we're yelling and the guy didn't come
let's just drop him over the fence and I
watched that Dog Whisperer [ __ ] and I
see like when a dog comes up to the pack
and everybody starts freaking out and
I'm like I don't know about this guy's I
don't know so we lift the dogs up and
the pack of me is just like not a good
idea that I got we almost threw these
dogs to their death so we ended up put
them back in the truck I know there's a
couple people who know a lot of stuff
about dogs right now don't worry it has
a happy ending okay so you can relax all
right
get off the edge of your staple seat
your IKEA chair this has a good ending
so we ended up going to the track we
parked in the shade and the dogs
immediately just you know passed out
they were so exhausted poor things and
they were friendly as hell so when we
were done we ended up just looking up
the Humane Society and they had a
drop-off we went over there we came
walking in with them didn't have leashes
were like carrying them in and [ __ ] and
we come walking like hey how you doing
my whole head is like please you're not
gonna kill these dogs in like 20 minutes
right so we brought him in a second we
came walking and they're like Jesus
Christ those dogs are back again we know
those dogs and you know they said they
were microchipped scan dumb and [ __ ] and
which was unsettling because one of my
buddies is going like oh these things
are micro checked chip you know then the
conspiracy theorist and me is just like
yeah we're next that's what they're
gonna do they bring us into it after we
escaped a Fema camp want your papers
pretty easy and they're gonna [ __ ]
tackle you scan you and send you right
back to your camp in Fresno but let's
get back to the happy ending so they
knew the dogs they scan them they called
the owner and then they ended up coming
down to get the dog so we did a good
date all right that's why the podcast is
late because I was acting like a [ __ ]
eight-year-old but we rescued dogs along
the way isn't that a nice story I got to
tell you something if you never gone
dirtbike riding you got to do it and I
can't imagine when
saw some of the kids down there getting
to ride those bikes like how [ __ ]
incredible that must be you know so
remember when you were a kid you just
sitting there riding in the back you're
always the passenger and then all of a
sudden one day you turn 15 15 and a half
you get your permit next and you're
driving down the street it's the
greatest [ __ ] feeling ever to feel
that at 8 to go from literally like like
[ __ ] a half hour later but dad dad
dad flying around the track it's just
incredible to me but anyways it was an
awesome time and I don't know but I
don't know if I have time for another
hobby and I got to tell you like you
know it was fun but it's [ __ ] scary I
didn't know I was doing one point like I
let out the clutch and I just started
flying I'm in the parking lot it's all
dirt and I'm heading towards these trees
and these cars and fortunately I remain
calm and I had to like I had to like
think what do you do I'll push in the
clutch and here's the brake ok and it's
the exact opposite where you know I'm
used to driving my truck I push in the
clutch with my foot brakes obviously
with the foot and now it's the opposite
unless she used the back brake which is
on the right side the whole [ __ ]
thing but I was able to make it was
hilarious I stopped and when I turned
around I saw everybody in the parking
lot was laughing and I was just sitting
there like dude I am just a [ __ ]
YouTube video waiting to have I this I
am I I should have had epic fail written
across my shoulder so it was it was a
little sketchy in the beginning but I
just kept you know you know I watched a
couple of YouTube videos on how to ride
a motorcycle they were just like look
just keep you know keep it in first gear
let out the clutch get going a little
bit and then learn how to stuff and they
just keep doing that over and over again
so I just kept doing that over and over
again so when she can slow the [ __ ]
down
you're alright and I was I got it into
second gear a couple of times but like I
said I wasn't you know I wasn't trying
to break my collarbone or even worse
[ __ ] be a lawn dart
I'm just not I'm not I'm too old I can't
make it come back from that [ __ ] you
know
you know kids are all positive they like
fall out of a skyscraper and like good
put on some cartoons they like up and
walking in like a week like that that
would have broke me as a human being I'm
not I'm just a [ __ ] talking [ __ ] but
when it comes to stuff like that like
I'm not I I know my limits I [ __ ]
know there was a couple of times I got
it up in the second gear and that
[ __ ] voice that you ignore when
you're a youngster that voice that's
going to it what the [ __ ] are you doing
and just plays out the scenario you know
of laying in the back of the ambulance
and that guy flashing the pen light in
your eyes just playing out that scenario
and all the canceled gigs I would have
and and every time you know it [ __ ]
it's below 30 degrees out my [ __ ]
liver hurts like I just played all of
that every time I thought of that I just
kept slowing down so but it was [ __ ]
awesome and and and that's it there you
go
there's my dirtbike story that's why I'm
late all right okay so this is the
Monday morning podcast everybody did you
got you did you watch some [ __ ]
sports about them cell ticks the [ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] said it oh yeah [ __ ] you're such
a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude the [ __ ] Celtics
tied it up holy [ __ ] amazing I got to
tell you something right now
I haven't the utmost respect for fans of
the NBA it is the most [ __ ] up
nerve-racking game it's it's I can't
even explain it no team can go up by 20
points and [ __ ] hold the lead they
just can't do it up by 24 and all of a
sudden Stern calls the refs - [ __ ] you
guys don't what the rule is 15 points 15
or more and then they just start to
tweak - tweet tweet tweet foul away from
the ball
all and I've never watched this sport
where you hear the announcers review a
call like six times a game they go I
don't know what he was looking at there
anyways Rondo pushes the ball upcourt
you know how many [ __ ] times it's the
most frustrating sport I've ever watched
in my life when the Celtics we're up by
oh yeah by like 15 or whatever scores 61
in the first half and then all sudden
you score 28 in the second half it's
like what is going on with that's that
doesn't make any sense to me
like when a pitcher comes out and he's
on and he's got his stuff he has his
stuff he doesn't like pitch pitch lights
out for for ratings and then like led up
like 19 [ __ ] home runs doesn't happen
he's [ __ ] NBA they said they're up by
24 points and then all of a sudden they
do they can't get a call they can't get
a bucket and all of a sudden X it's a
[ __ ] nail-biter
we were up by 24 points after three
quarters game 324 Peter scored 24 points
that's a solid quarter worth the [ __ ]
points and somehow it went down to being
like an eight point game and I was just
losing my [ __ ] and the more I was
watching it I was just convinced that
it's manipulated by the refs I don't
give a [ __ ] what you say there's no
other official that has more power than
an NBA referee they can kick people out
of the [ __ ] game okay you can call a
tension around on Peyton Manning you can
call uh you know some [ __ ] forward
lateral or some crap but you can't kick
Tom Brady out of the goddamn game unless
he throws a punch you know what I mean I
guess you can is he in verbally abuse
you a touch the rim but he has to do
something but in basketball you can just
call phantom fouls like if I bet if I
bet the game this is all you got to do
who's the best player on that team this
is what you do right out of the gate you
give him two quick fouls now he's on the
[ __ ] bench probably for the rest of
the first quarter he comes out in the
second quarter now you got to give him
his third but you know you gotta wait a
few minutes you know however the game's
going you wait a few minutes then you
get mastered
right so it sounds in foul trouble third
quarter starts he's on the [ __ ] bench
and now you want the other team to make
a run that [ __ ] Oh comes off the bench
you give miss fourth T them up maybe a
couple of technicals there I think I
watched that game yesterday
it goes into overtime it's a playoff
game Paul Pierce fouls out LeBron James
fouls out two [ __ ] best guys out
there arguably you know and they're
sitting on the bench you don't watch
hockey and all of a sudden [ __ ] you
know whoever you want to co the [ __ ]
even in the finals now le ah Sh
you know Zach Parise whoever the [ __ ]
you say their names I hate the Devils I
never watch him you know oh that's his
third [ __ ] cross-check that said he's
out of the game and like the bet like
Gretzky Lemieux are just sitting there
on the bench fouled out and then like
the scrubs come in and they can't hit
[ __ ] free-throws III just it's
unbelievably frustrating frustrating
[ __ ] game to watch but we tied up
what tied up so did that make any
goddamn sense if you guys ever watched
those YouTube videos when you see when
you see what's-his-face when you see
that whole Sacramento series Sacramento
Kings that was against the LA Lakers in
2002 series that was allegedly fixed you
saw right there how to fix a game they
just fouled out both their centers on
[ __ ] [ __ ] calls and then she just
let Shaq run wild they still almost lost
the game I don't know man
you know what it is I'm so sick of
people like being a hockey fan unless
you run into another hockey fan it's the
weirdest sport to be a fan of cuz people
just [ __ ] although well why do they let
them fight I can't see the puck and
after watching the NBA for like the last
three weeks it's like what are you
worried about the mobbed-up refs
in your league you know I think the NBA
is is basically it's a pure game it's a
beautiful game but it's basically a
traveling gambling ring as far as I can
tell the players gamble with each other
they get into fistfights on planes they
bring guns to the [ __ ] arena you had
mobbed-up ref you know and then they
pulled the Lee Harvey Oswald he acted a
lone horseshit
right you have the biggest star of the
game has to mysteriously just retires
for a year and a half and then one of
his loved ones essentially is murdered
like execution-style like there's a lot
of [ __ ] there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
so why don't you go [ __ ] yourselves with
your criticisms of hockey okay I can
recognize NBA is a great game but your
league
it's a little [ __ ] up and as far as
you guys who can't see the puck why
don't you start by looking at the guy
that everybody seems to be focused on
all right that's usually the guy with
the puck the black object against the
white surface that you for some reason
can't see speaking of which I'm trying
to go to game for the LA Kings you know
what's the best thing about about the LA
Kings making the playoffs is listening
to the local spa sports radio shows like
have to talk hockey dude they are
[ __ ] flailing out here at least that
that Max and Marcellus show that's the
show I always listen to and they're
great and everything but when it comes
to hockey they don't know a [ __ ]
thing
Max is just hitting you with basic
feather they got there quicker than any
other team uh big team they're playing
together he's nothing
the guys got nothing this is funny like
two weeks early I was listening to his
show and some jackass called him was go
I'm a casual fan of hockey I go to a
couple games a year you know if they
just would tell you what a cross-check
is it's like right there it's like dude
you're not a casual [ __ ] fan that
would be likes me saying I'm a casual
fan of the NBA I go to a couple games a
year if they just tell me what traveling
is it's like how do you not pick that up
within the first [ __ ] period and a
half all the criticism criticism against
hockey's silver dick I don't when they
go why do they have to half times it's
like dude why don't you go back to basic
math and realize that it's
mathematically you can't have two half
times right they have a third time and a
2/3 time you want to get technical
technical correct all right anyway so
this is the podcast hey you know what
time it is it's time for some [ __ ]
advertise
what do you say fun is coming up
everybody if it wasn't for your dad
looking at your mom wanting to get down
you wouldn't be here right this is a
thing about Mother's Day you go all out
on Mother's Day everybody does right you
just go all out it's your mom she's a
saint right you go all out and what
happens Father's Day your father is
basically Walter Payton and Super Bowl
20 remember they let the fridge the
fridge is your mom right the [ __ ]
popular one hand it off to her and
sweetness doesn't get a touchdown all
right well I think it's high time you
let your dad [ __ ] run one in all
right and you can do it with the man
great
what is the man great you you ask well
when you go out and you look at your
father's grill he's gonna have one of
those grills where they have those
little skinny little grills you know
what I mean that you couldn't even you
couldn't even put like a cheese it on
without it falling through you know this
is what the man grade is it's basically
it's a grill enhancement system which
means you don't have to go buy a new
grill this is going to enhance it you
ever go into those awesome steak houses
and you look at there's this psycho
mesquite grill that they have and those
really thick grates that they have and a
little the little moat thing to catch
the grease so there's no grease fires
there basically they finally made one I
don't know why it took so long for
someone to do this but they finally made
one for your grill at home which
basically now you're gonna get the the
the the the look and the flavor of a
real steak house all right bait and this
is the best part 100% made in America
cast-iron grilling grates
what are we make in America huh weed and
this I think that's all we have left all
right this is actually legal in all 50
states
all right 100% made in America Cass
styling iron grilling grates they're
heavy-duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
steakhouse flavor that you've been
looking for
man grates got the patented design is
great for chicken steak veggies all that
stuff was never going to taste so good
you don't have any more flip flare-ups
or dry meat guaranteed take advantage of
the $20 monday-morning Park
special today by clicking on Matt on the
man great banner at billboard.com just
go on the podcast page as a bonus every
billboard comm order comes with a heavy
duty man great grilling brush come on
man that's what you buy your dad right
there okay that's one buying your dad a
man great for Father's Day is one rung
below just buying them like an old
pistol it's just a manly thing to get
them 100% made in America 100% cast-iron
Steakhouse quality $20 off and you get
you a little your little wire brush
there huh who's hooking you up who's
hooking you up wow how could you do
better how could you do better you know
get him a hook ah dad you've been
faithful all these years Oh his is a is
a an email from somebody talking about
NBA refs
cuz I was like convinced that the NBA is
fixed or at the very least manipulated
you know oh my god the lottery are you
serious the lottery the Knicks win the
first one ever because you want Patrick
Ewing to go to New York City of course
absolutely
the foul away from the ball I don't know
what he was looking at their NBA rest
bill saw your tweet about NBA refs and
how they are in it for the money well
it's the truth
this guy's claiming that this is the
truth this is all alleged before I get
sued by a conglomerate of those
footlocker jackasses I'm friends with
the daughter of one of one of the top
paid reps in the league I just went to a
wedding on Friday night and there were
two tables of NBA refs they're no lie I
can provide picks for verification I
don't want any pictures don't send me
any pictures I don't want to rat anybody
out here I just think it's hilarious
anyways anyway I know that refs gets
paid referees get paid 10 grand per game
for the NBA Finals so if the series gets
swept it's it's 40 grand but if it goes
to seven games that's a difference of 30
grand I work in finance and that's a lot
of coin for next 2-3 days of work plus
the network gets more money from
advertisers etc although a sport
uh although a sport it's a major
business I don't know what that sentence
means former ref Tim Donaghy got busted
for gambling on games a while back and
wrote a book about it this is my
favorite thing they say that that guy
has no credibility you know that's what
they said about Jose Canseco when he
first came out and you know was ratting
everybody out oh he's old he's bitter
he's turned his back on baseball wait a
minute he's right oh sorry about that
you know plus if you say he has no
credibility then you have to like let
80% of people out of prison because
that's how they ended up in prison the
person they did the crime with was
negotiating their their [ __ ] sentence
down and they ratted him out right I
think the NBA is filthy
you know Pete Rose bets on baseball he's
banned from baseball for life
Jordan bets on it he gets to go play
baseball allegedly allegedly former ref
Tim Donaghy got busted for gambling on
games a while back and wrote a book
about it
the guy is from the same neighborhood as
I am and we know some of the same people
the guy who does my homeowner's
insurance was named as a gambling
partner in the first chapter it's
eye-opening of how shady the business is
and how refs can cheat so easily to fix
the outcome of a game
according to Tim Toya Donnie this is all
alleged people all alleged Philadelphia
is a hotbed for NBA reps and I actually
went to high school with an act of NBA
ref who was also at the above-mentioned
wedding
I love the podcast but just started
listening a few months ago how could I
download the podcast dude you didn't
really say anything you just said you
went to a wedding with some NBA refs you
know how much they make a game but you
didn't really provide any that's all
circumstantial
I don't know it just seems so filthy
like they call like the when they call
those ticky tack fouls
I'm telling you they're thinking ahead
in the game as how I look at it like I I
get Paul Pierce fouls out but like those
[ __ ] ticky TAC files that you call
on him in the beginning of the game is
how he ends up filing out when the
when he actually files somebody so I
don't I don't know I don't get it I'm
sitting there watching us we got a
15-point lead and then all of a sudden
within a minute Paul Pierce and Rondo
both pick up their fourth files have to
sit down and next thing you know it's a
game again you know so I don't know that
they necessarily learn that I have when
I watch the NBA
I feel like somewhere around 14 15 point
lead in the playoffs playoffs yeah
that's when all of a sudden you know
calls start going the other way because
they don't want people to turn the
channels at the end of the [ __ ] day
it's a business they keep it closed just
keep it closed that's what they're doing
I don't know I'm an [ __ ] don't listen
to me but I on a percent it just
wouldn't surprise me if somebody came
out they actually found out that like
18% that's a little high I'd say 11
percent of NBA games are strongly
manipulated I would be surprised that a
product that it wasn't more like 18% cuz
when I just watch them it's just like
how many times can they just be like
there's like no follow and that did [ __ ]
I know I talked about it last week but
Kobe hacks a guy across both [ __ ]
arms they call him for his third foul in
the second quarter you know he's gonna
sit down that's gonna affect the casual
fan watching they have a 90 second
meeting and then they give the file to
somebody else and that's a business move
right [ __ ] there
and then the announces I don't know what
they looking at there right Kobe
bringing it up the court he's [ __ ]
nuts
shoot the front there's a foul away from
the ball cheese what was he looking at
I don't know must have been something
before the video there was act a acts
like perplexed all right here's a
sexuality situation everybody um hey
Bill I need your advice on something
this is a not this is not about a
breakup dating or gold diggers but I
think your advice could help me could
help me out on an extremely awkward
position I'm 19 and I'm home from
college for the summer I've been home
for about a month and I live in North
Carolina but go to college in Arizona
dude good move Arizona with all those
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there coming to class
and like bikini tops and you're out
there with you cuter than cute Southern
drawl how much ass are you gettin well
let's find out shall we okay while I was
away at college I have opened up to new
ideas such as politics politics religion
and about my sexuality and my bison and
I am bisexual at the beginning of summer
I started hanging out with my old
friends from high school one of which
was gay
we had messed around in high school but
nothing serious what does that mean you
flicked his balls a little bit sorry the
[ __ ] joke is there I'm gonna do it
all right come on take it like a man
like everybody else okay everybody gets
trashed on this here we go so this
summer he and I were hanging out at my
house and nobody was home we started and
we started to drinking oh gee she's
playing some music YMCA and he started
to smoke some weed man then after about
two hours we decided to do the dirty
Jesus Christ okay here we go
halfway through us getting it on my mom
walks into the room and catches us in
the act Wow now talk about the needle
going off the [ __ ] record she started
yelling at me
swatting me with the mail she had just
gotten I'm surprised she didn't turn the
hose on you kick my friend out of the
house then banned him from ever coming
over again and started screaming about
the Bible and a bunch of religious [ __ ]
by the way this all happened when I was
in a in a panic trying to get some
clothes oh my god dude what a way to
come out the only thing was Mitchell
it's a giant neon I'm gay sign hanging
over you wow that's a [ __ ] situation
there huh ever since then my mom and dad
have been forcing me to go to a few
religious nut jobs that are supposed to
convert me from bisexual to head
sexual that's hilarious you know like
you're gonna convert a truck from
two-wheel drive to four-wheel drive like
it's that [ __ ] easy this is a huge
pain in the ass because one there are
churches on every corner in North
Carolina and two I don't want to change
so you shouldn't dude you can't you are
who you [ __ ] are and they're gonna
have to accept it also my parents have
been treating me differently now and
it's really weird and awkward every time
we talk so I guess my question is how do
I deal with this dude this might be
outside the mother realm of my lack of
extra expertise here do I tell them that
I don't want to go to some religious fat
[ __ ] who was a Jesus Freak and whose
stomach is as long as his vowels
I always got that Southern drawl you
can't be sucking deyette or should I
just pretend to be straight until the
end of summer then go back to living the
life I want to live at college also how
do I keep saying with people telling me
that I am living my life wrong and that
God is judging me I hope that wasn't too
sad dude it's a [ __ ] epic story thank
you for sharing it here all right this
is a deal dude you you need new friends
you need to keep the friends that accept
you for who you are and the ones who
aren't you just gotta phase them out
your parents your parents will come
around you know they gotta come around
cuz you're this son all right
stereotypically probably your mom before
your dad or whatever but I don't know if
maybe they will maybe they won't but
what the [ __ ] you gonna do you know you
are who you are you got to go be who
you're gonna be and as far as do you
tough it out for this summer that that's
up that's up to you that's up to you if
you're gonna keep going back I mean if I
was gonna keep going back to some [ __ ]
that I want to didn't want to go to I
would just I would have fun with it I
would just act like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I would keep acting like I was almost
cured and then at the last second be
like but don't you think John Travolta's
cute oh no no sorry sorry and just [ __ ]
with the guy you just have a good time
if you can't get out of it
if you don't wanna you know fight you
know if you don't be like Hitler and try
and fight on three fronts and end up in
a [ __ ] bunker
maybe you just start with the get some
new [ __ ] friends that's it dude
that's brutal man that's brutal but uh
you'll get through it you'll get through
it you'll find some [ __ ] people you
know sweet in a weird way everybody does
that beyond that [ __ ] you know as a
comedian I never fit in anywhere
everywhere I went like when I [ __ ]
had jobs and they would be sitting there
and I had my little Michael J Fox
[ __ ] suit and tie on like thinking
that that this is what I was gonna do
and everybody was going in for some
[ __ ] meeting I'd never gave a [ __ ]
and I never I just felt always felt like
an outsider until the day I walked into
a comedy club and I basically found
people who were the same kind of weird
that I was so they didn't seem weird to
me but admittedly comedians were all out
of our [ __ ] minds so that's what you
have to do in a gay way you just got to
go find some heterosexuals who were
accepting of you and go get some gay
friends and you know you can have a
great life and you're gonna have abs
until you're 60 evidently because that's
how it works with gay people
[ __ ] them be who you are and that's it
all right there you go
all right dealing with girlfriend's mom
girlfriend's mother dear Billiam I'm 24
years old you know it's funny I always
do this this Boston accent I think that
it [ __ ] with my language for the rest
of the week my language no my accent for
the rest week I'm 24 years old and
recently started let's let's see if I
can pronounce my arse through all this
I'm 24 years old and recently started
started dating a new gal she's a
complete sweetheart
sorry also 24 years old but her mom
already hates me what do you got a
mullet you got an earring
you got a loud car do you got that look
I'm gonna [ __ ] your daughter what's
going on with you he says I'm a pretty
successful guy from my age college
graduate I have a house legit office job
etc how the [ __ ] you got a house at 24
do you come from money are you dealing
dude if you're a college graduate and
you legitimately found a job were able
to buy a house like I don't know like
you're probably like one of five people
from your generation that's able to do
that with this [ __ ] economy so I'll
give you the benefit of the doubt
congratulations I'll give you the
benefit of the doubt that you don't have
a meth lab in your bathroom anyways the
girl that girls lives at home
I mean before she was before me she was
dating a guy in medical school her mom
crept through my facebook profile and
decided based on the suburb I'm from the
school I went to and the fact I'm not a
doctor I'm not good enough for her
daughter which means she probably
pressured her daughter to go date a
[ __ ] doctor
or you know she dated a doctor trying to
make her mom happy that's what I'm
guessing I'm with my lack of a
psychology degree but my my cynical
everybody's a [ __ ] way of looking at
stuff well after three months of dating
and accepting I might be around for a
while they finally agreed to meet me
her dad seems like a nice guy it's just
the mom I have to air quote impress so
here's the issue I can't play the
redneck redneck stereotype too hard by
wearing acid-washed jeans and a Def
Leppard t-shirt because my girl will get
pissed off but to my my advantage I own
two cars both of which will annoy her
and deem me a [ __ ] hick which option
in your opinion would be funnier parked
in the wrap around driveway of their
million dollar house and now he sent me
pictures of his two [ __ ] sweet rides
he's got a 2006 Ford Mustang GT this is
my daily driver it's blue with silver
racing stripes and lowered to inches I
have the cat's removed and full exhaust
I don't know what that means what
catalytic converters I have no idea what
that even means I just love that you
assumed that I knew so it's loud as [ __ ]
and it's a five-speed so I can play like
I sucked at driving a stick and do the
rev and release clutch move that all 60
olds do that should rattle their
stainless steel appliances and granite
countertops number two I got a 19
91 Ford f150 4x4 my bad weather /
housework
I think you've beater wrote better 351
Windsor [ __ ] two-tone red and
white single cab red bench seat it has
plenty of NRA stickers on the back from
the previous owner my favorite being
fight crime shoot back I'll do that's
that's a wrap that's a wrap you got it I
think you got to go with the truck
fender wells a rusty a rusting out and
there's several rust holes in the bed it
also leaks coolant and oil and would
leave a nice stain in the driveway I
don't plan on being a dick or anything
when I meet them but if she's gonna
judge me without even knowing me I'd
hate to let her down and close their
pictures of both cars and the bumper
sticker on the truck please advise
that's what we say at the end of emails
in [ __ ] corporate America oh please
please advise those are beautiful cars
man I love two-toned pickup trucks too
by the way
this is what I yeah pull up pull up in
your pickup and then the next time you
come over you come over in the car and
that'll do the other stereotype that
people who don't come from money always
you know by depreciating assets I don't
do it all depends on how much you care
about this girl because I your whole
attitude is perfect you shouldn't give a
[ __ ] whether she likes you or not you
really shouldn't there's nothing you can
do about it just you know romance or
daughter if you love her if you don't
get rid of her don't stick around just
out of spite but I would definitely go
with the pickup truck man to pick up
trucks [ __ ] hilarious but you know
something the Mustangs cool to them that
Mustang says I you know I'm gonna bang
your daughter before we even get to the
restaurant and it's loud maybe the
Mustang do you get a mullet how about a
clip on earring I don't know anyways
anyways what the [ __ ] else happened to
me here I got to click back to my notes
here there's a couple of stories I want
to tell you I told the motorcycle one
right didn't I [ __ ]
nine hours [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is what
the hell is it you know what this
[ __ ] computer man oh yeah how sick
you guys listen to me [ __ ] about my
computer let me just get rid of this oh
[ __ ] you know what I went to on was it
Wednesday at last week Thursday last
week I went down to the House of Blues
they had the John Bonham birthday bash
it's become this yearly thing with this
discover band basically not cup of Ben
it's like these insane [ __ ] musician
I guess they're all playing Led Zeppelin
they come out and then all these
drummers sit in and they and they play
all these Zeppelin tunes and it's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] man and there was some guys
out there who really really impressed me
Simon it was it was crazy
Freddy cupcake curry the nicest guy in
rock and roll now if you remember that
from MTV headbangers ball you're showing
your age he played a custard pie and
Simon Wright the drummer for ac/dc from
83 to 90 he took over when Phil Rudd got
kicked out and right before they did
razor's edge 1990 he left to go play
with do and all I I never really
listened to do at least that part of his
career and all I heard was I'm just
playing the ac/dc stuff which was total
two-four two-four stuff and he came out
and played the ocean and he [ __ ]
crushed it phenomenal drummer but more
importantly the last time I saw both
those guys on the same night I saw them
play the old Boston Garden Cinderella
was opening up for 8th ac/dc on the
Heatseeker tour uh you jealous isn't it
isn't it amazing that it took me 43
years to find dirt bikes when you hear
that story but uh Freddy curry played
custard pie and I felt it was too
different they were all the drummers
there were great but I felt there was
two kinds of drummers that night there
was the drummer that was going up there
that loved John Bonham and was paying
tribute to him and and understood
what it was that John Bonham did and
then there was the other guy so what's
this was a small portion went up there
and it was just a jerk-off festival that
they were gonna go up there and show
that they could play all the [ __ ]
licks and they were playing all over the
kit throughout the song and it just I
don't know one guy saw put the drumstick
in his between his teeth as he was just
playing with his right hand and I was
just thinking you know Bonham would have
smashed a snare drum over your [ __ ]
head what are you doing what are you
doing I mean was he biting on it cuz he
felt like he [ __ ] up a lick I have no
idea but it was annoying [ __ ] annoyed
me oh it started off great the guy who
organizes it Brian tishy I think he
organized it he played in the evening I
mean he just [ __ ] crushed it and I
was in my John Bonham glory and and then
Sebastian Bach came out and sang a whole
lot of love it was it was just a [ __ ]
and the last time I saw Sebastian Bach
live was December 31st 1989 I had just
lost my light license for drinking and
driving and I saw Aerosmith at the
Boston Garden to bring in the decade in
the 1990s that's how I went out of the
80s it was on the Dunn not don't I
always say done with mirrors it was the
pump tour and Smith was sober by then so
they started [ __ ] incredible and that
was that classic story I told you where
when that concert was going on was right
around the time when another bad egg
that the United States had invested in
Manuel Noriega down in Panama all of a
sudden wasn't doing what the [ __ ] we
wanted to do wanted them to do you know
the deal all these dirtbags they're all
doing [ __ ] that we don't want them to do
but they're doing what we need them to
do so it's okay and then the second they
stopped doing what we needed to do all
of a sudden we're outraged that they
gassed their own people [ __ ] 12 years
earlier how could he have done that in
1973 yeah we gotta go in and get this
guy right it's like the [ __ ] Kobe
Bryant foul 90 seconds later they give
it to somebody else is like what the
[ __ ] you've been talking about so
anyways so you know they're pumping us
with all the information about
Manuel Noriega none of it is good so you
know so he goes up there in the middle
of this [ __ ] metal show he decides I
know I told this story before but I love
this story he decided out of the [ __ ]
blue that did go political I remember he
was standing on stage so he might have
been drunk just just you know for him to
save face but he was wearing these
leather pants and I just stand there he
goes what's up with this man well and he
grabbed his dick and he goes suck my
[ __ ] burrito man horrific and it was
his awkward pause and everything just
went hi Bree starts cheering he goes I
see he said something about going down
there and [ __ ] nuking him it was the
classic and for all you [ __ ] over in
England the guys from Canada to go [ __ ]
yourselves
alright you think another typical stupid
guy from the state's alright and he
might have been pandering but I got to
tell you we all cheered
that's right Sebastian you figure out
Central America and then play slave to
the grind
oh no no that was their first tour
that's a new singing 18 like you got it
right all the chicks like oh my god look
at me when I take my tits out not in her
oh those were the days all those [ __ ]
fish knitted [ __ ] there's photos the
greatest [ __ ] thing ever
I'm really so happy that I grew up
during that time rather than the grunge
period when all those hairy chicks were
just [ __ ] walking around with this
sash watching muffs you know high and
tight 80s baby it was right before
they're really bad there's two things
that were really bad in the 90s like you
know that grunge music you know the top
tier I like all right but there was a
lot of moping around just because moping
around was selling albums the same way
with hair metal there was a lot of [ __ ]
about the devil and you know they
weren't really sacrificing anybody right
it was only the top shelf that were but
anyways
the the mopey music of the 90s and then
the [ __ ] the just absolutely perfect
circle horrific grapefruit fake tits
where you had like a varicose vein on
the side of your titty like those two of
the worst things from the 90s I would
say you know one of the best things of
the 90s I would say would be Soundgarden
I'd go with them they [ __ ] suck yeah
actually ripped up I don't give a [ __ ]
you guys like me anytime your computer
comes up and says hey there's new
software available yeah would you like
to download it and you got that option
not now you know like hitting the snooze
alarm on your [ __ ] computer and then
one day you go to your iTunes doesn't
work now the video works and then you
yell at your computer like it's the it's
the problem that's what I like to do hey
everybody have you been to the post
office lately yeah how did that work out
wouldn't it be wonderful if somehow you
could take the enormity of the stuff the
postal industry and just stick it inside
your view of your apartment put it right
your little sleeping bag wouldn't it be
great well I'm here to tell you that
that's a possibility
if you go to stamps.com everybody you
can stop one of the biggest waste of
times in your life right now which is
going to the post office especially when
you got a business to run or maybe you
just want to sit down and eat a sandwich
right that's why you need stamp stop
come it's not only gonna save you time
you can buy and print official US
postage using your own computer or a
friend's and a printer print exact
postage for any letter right from your
desk using the free digital scale the
exact posters for a letter or package
sorry I read that wrong
basically anything you want to ship you
can stick that baby in a box and put it
on a scale you know maybe you need some
help late now you got a friend right you
have him pick it up you put it on the
damn scale you weigh it
you put the postage right on you walk
out you put in your post-office box
whatever your mailbox and then you go
right back to watching t-bill we know we
know what we would do if we had the post
office in our own apartments or houses
or out houses or tents do you live in a
tent city do you have an outlet buy
stamps calm but
stamps.com will also give you money it's
a fraction of the cost of a postage
meter plus you get discounts you can't
even get at the post office that's a
great thing if you get in early with
stamps calm because once it blows up you
know that they're not gonna have any of
these discounts so you get in early all
right I'm sure me to get a note on that
actually we plan on having discounts
forever right now if you use my last
name Barbie you are our for this special
offer you get a no risk trial plus a
hundred and ten dollar bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to fifty
five dollars in free postage don't wait
this is the call to action everybody go
to stamp stop stamps calm right now
before you do anything else click on the
radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Barbie you are our
that stamps comm enter ber and you will
be in the wonderful world of not having
to go to the post office anymore you
know that'd be great what if you had the
grocery store in your own apartment
that's probably next go to grocery store
come would it be great if lemons fell
out of your ceiling do you know the
wonderful the beautiful the lovely Nia
has been she's been on a tear lately you
know planting all this [ __ ] out in the
yard and none of its edible so we're
having this big fight like she likes
pretty no it's like you can't [ __ ]
eat that [ __ ] you know why don't we get
a you know like a watermelon tree or
something right watermelon so go [ __ ]
yourself I know they don't grow on trees
you know what I mean let's get something
edible out here let's grow some goddamn
potatoes you know just grow some [ __ ]
food that's what I want to do they got
those little dwarf trees like a [ __ ] a
grapefruit tree they got a [ __ ]
avocado tree and they just you just
stick him in a barrel and there you go
pakka licks comes here comes Jesus
throwing all the sinners down into hell
and you just sitting there eating
avocados like go [ __ ] yourself you
hippie I got a food supply what do you
gotta do to make huh
the end of the day I know you're a
pacifist I know you don't got it in you
you don't have that rage like your dad
does talent skips a generation all right
why don't you go play the [ __ ]
maracas and get out of my face I know
that's not your three
dog that's your dad's yeah go for look I
respect you dad I'm not disrespecting
I'm disrespecting you
yeah I'm sure that's how you're gonna
tell this story you [ __ ] [ __ ] right
all while you're eating an avocado or a
grapefruit or some [ __ ] like that
you know recently I worked with somebody
and they said something about they said
something about the microwave I don't
think I can ever use one again
he said they microwave water to boiling
point and let it cool down and then they
boiled some water on the stove and they
watered two rows of flowers and the
water with the microwave water they all
died so I'm all set on the microwave
that's all it takes if it kills a plant
what's it doing to me I don't know I'm
easily scared everybody and I'm afraid
I'm not I'm not trusting so if you have
any remote like theory on anything like
you know I would literally phase out
living in a house if you had a good
enough lie as to why it was slowly
killing me anyways what else do we got
here
what other I promised I would resend
this to you run this whenever you would
like all right this is spotify dot-com
all right this is one of these places
that you know for Christ's sake what is
this this is the graphic image why don't
I have this stuff ready the worst you
know this is why I'm a comedian because
I swear to God if I was in the real
world and I had some sort of
presentation I would be the guy showing
up with like the papers falling out of
my briefcase when I met this safe I
would be like the Nutty Professor but I
would never turn into the cool guy Jerry
Lewis is by the way what is Spotify it's
a new way to listen listen to free to
listen to music for free
millions of tracks artists and even
comedic content is on there for you to
access whenever you want I know what a
lot of you guys think of Bill why are
you hyping this stuff when you had a
problem with that other site because
this site actually is gonna pay me for
my material so I don't have a problem
with them so
- Spotify everybody this is what the way
I I think about Spotify is iTunes but
with the entire world's live all is this
one I'm supposed to say this is what I
think you guys are speaking for me
evidently Spotify is like iTunes but
with the entire world's library at your
fingertips well right there that's
better than iTunes how many times you go
on iTunes you go to look up a band and
they don't have it unless it's like the
biggest thing ever you know like your
guilty pleasures I did it that good
they'll actually have the B tracks of
Britney Spears on Spotify it works on a
PC it works on a Mac home audio system
and mobile phones tracks play live
there's no need to wait for downloads
and no big dents in your hard drive
Spotify connects seamlessly with your
Facebook account and allows to easily
discover new music and share them with
friends super easy to use and here's
what you do you go to the Spotify link
on the website click register from your
Facebook account download Spotify to
your Windows or Mac computer search and
play the millions of songs that are now
yours doing it this way will give you
free access access to Spotify and it's
really just that simple bill do you have
a deal for us yes I do for every one of
my listeners that I Drive to uh those is
the actual deal that I get every one I
Drive there I get a free quarter of a
grilled cheese sandwich for listeners
that's uh um banner ad is attached to
the email we don't you have this up yet
I'm gonna have to go Jesus Christ why
did I do that you know you did that's
like he just got somebody's leaked copy
the tracks of that new album we're gonna
have that up for next week everybody old
Spotify dot-com boy oh boy this is the
greatest thing ever says bill I like
when this copy like that I don't have to
think um anyway so let's get back to the
podcast here what do we got here do we
got some overrated underwriters we got
to wind this down here right what are we
up to an hour and two minutes bill yeah
be here leaving him wanting more alright
we've gone through the advice dealing
with girlfriends mom or his last one
it's entitled virgin
Virgen hey who here witness still bang
Madonna huh I just now she'd be so
[ __ ] annoying though
just shut up you're from Detroit you're
not fooling me with your dumb accident
I'm 21 years old
dude just graduate to Bobby Kelly right
this time 21 years old good do you guys
listen to the what the [ __ ] podcast or
Christopher Titus this podcast and I'm
gonna be on that I don't even know the
name of actually just went and did his
podcast I didn't even learn the goddamn
name of it because I'm so wrapped up in
my own thing you know what's funny is I
went to the search thing and I actually
searched cricket is gay because I wanted
to see what Jason Alexander said Chris
Titus podcast you know what's great
about us doing the podcast if there's
any video of it you guys can actually
see that we are two different people
Titus podcast.com there we go this is
what you do you go to Titus podcast.com
and there's all kinds of music alright
just called the tightest podcast he's
got a cool logo the son of a [ __ ]
anyways I did one of his and I actually
just tweeted at this this week so there
you go there's your homework this week
listen to the what the [ __ ] dude no no
what the [ __ ] oh you know what dude what
the [ __ ] is meirin's you know what dude
is bobby Kelly's and the Christopher
Titus podcast go to Titus podcast calm
alright if you like this podcast hell
you might even like those
alright virgin I'm a 21 year old virgin
dude just graduated from college in LA
is that Louisiana or Los Angeles and one
of my bigger issues that was a great
Dennis Miller joke a long time ago just
got back from LA I love Louisiana yeah
any one of my bigger issues in my life
right now is that I'm still a virgin
do 21 that's not bad I'm not attractive
I'm not unattractive or anything I work
out have a bit of an issue with acne but
it's nothing like having a gigantic pus
ball in my face I was in a relationship
with
since I was 14 and we ended it when I
was 20 because we just couldn't deal
with the long distance anymore and she
was really conservative Christian and I
guess I was naive and stupid enough to
tell her that I would wait that's all
right you're a good guy therefore the
more we went the most we went oh the
most we went to was just oral sex all
right do we you're not like a terminal
virgin you're actually doing you living
the life you get you having sex like you
have it like a one of those massage
parlors we came close a couple of times
but I would always back out because I
feel bad that I would be running off
with the virginity because at the back
of my mind I kind of knew this
relationship was never gonna work out
Jesus Christ dude you're a saint it
doesn't help that she and I have had the
same group of friends so if word got out
what I did that would have been seen as
a dick move now that I'm actually single
and looking for chicks and on occasion
I've actually managed to convince a few
to come home with me all right you're in
the game I feel this innate sense of
pressure that I wouldn't be able to
perform well and would end up
embarrassing myself due to lack of
experience dude in it you're gonna be
fine these nightly escapades would
therefore only tend to end up with
make-out sessions or the occasional
[ __ ] [ __ ] before i [ __ ] out
what do you think I should do
should actually do in a situation like
these when I'm taking a chick home who
probably has way more experience than I
do and I should just should I just take
a heavy dose of man the [ __ ] up and wing
it in the future I wouldn't think of
telling a girl that I'm a virgin before
[ __ ] her would sound remotely
attractive to her in any circumstance
what are your thoughts on this yeah dude
you know what you got to do just like
look you know I got good at playing
hockey or halfway decent upper level of
sucking you like I gradually got to the
truth on that I am at the upper upper
sucking not quite lower mediocre how I
got there was I played with people who
had more experience than me all right so
just slide that over to bang in the
these girls alright and I don't think
that they that girls out like that
they're not gonna what is she gonna do
oh my god you never [ __ ] anyone before
Jesus I [ __ ] like 900 guys then I gotta
say that think of me like oh and next
thing you know you'd be bang [ __ ]
doggy style that'll be a thrill for him
you know you put on the [ __ ]
soundtrack to the graduate you know you
have a good time yeah dude just just
look you know what the thing about this
is is the more you wait the bigger of a
[ __ ] deal it's gonna be you don't I
mean it's like your icing the kicker and
the kicker is your dick all right for
God's sake get out there and [ __ ]
blast it through the uprights that's
what you need to do alright and you
sound like you're doing great man you
you're a good guy do you realize the
[ __ ] the the the I don't know what it
is I don't even know what the word is
cuz none of my friends have this this
character trait I'm sure women know what
it is and they probably look for it in a
guy a gentleman Jesus I had a search for
what I would I just you're a human being
dude you're an honest guy
you could have bang this girl and you're
like I can't do it cuz I in the back of
my head you actually you know you know
you know it's funny you're probably
banging a couple girls you become a
piece of [ __ ] like me but right now dude
you're in the zone mother Theresa
couldn't [ __ ] with you you know Jesus
comes back tomorrow dude he's [ __ ]
you right up on that horse smelling of
patchouli when you [ __ ] grab around
his waist and right into heaven uh
confront a disgusting image anyways yeah
dude this just man the [ __ ] up wing in
the future and you know what you know
what I think we get rid of a lot of the
pressure why don't you just tell them
you know I don't know if you feel like
the moments they're just telling me you
just feel like the moments they're you
know what to get them the whole [ __ ]
story just in the middle of you just
telling me I never never did this before
okay you know next thing you got their
feet in the air I'm telling you you're
gonna be fine
all right and you're a good person and
then it's a deal dude you're a [ __ ]
virgin alright so you're like you still
got that new-car
Mel all right so whatever you do all
right
condoms from here on out condoms mehron
out no [ __ ] skanks alright because
evidently you maybe wear a condom you
can still get [ __ ] you know things I'm
not gonna do this so now you get even
more in your head right now what I just
did is now you finally lined up the
ticket to kick the field goal and I'm
sitting there waving my arms with the
[ __ ] air horn in the background you
know [ __ ] around it's like boxing
protect yourself at all times all right
that's all I'm gonna say okay alright
good luck to you that's the podcast for
this week apologize for being late
I hope my story about riding a
motorcycle what the [ __ ] happened in my
taint Jesus Christ I just sat in this
chair the wrong way my [ __ ] my
[ __ ] taint hurts [ __ ] you know what
it was was I went over a couple of
[ __ ] jumps and I got a little bit of
air I didn't know it enough to stand up
so I kind of came off the seat and then
landed and [ __ ] slam my taint he
liked that people i jacked my thumb up
my shoulders talking to me and I took a
nice [ __ ] slam a couple of slams to
the taint I'm gonna call the Comedy
Store tell them I can't perform this
week because of a bruised taint are you
[ __ ] with us I'm dead serious
hang on a second he got the iPhone I'll
take a video that's disgusting well it's
your fault for hanging out for the whole
podcast alright go [ __ ] yourself that's
the podcast for this week I'll talk to
you next week don't take any [ __ ] and
god bless everyone today okay alright
you